hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my Doctor Who finale video so
much better than last year's finale just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet so here we go just because this
is such a big deal I'm going to be doing
top 10 WTF and there is a new round of
the giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video
real simple so let's get going starting
with number 10 the doctor is back in
America now the difference here is that
the last time that we were in America
like this we were in Monument Valley
Utah and it says we're in Nevada here
surprise surprise though number 9 WTF we
are in the actual diner from series 6 so
we definitely know something's up
because Clara is the waitress the last
time we saw the diner though like the
doctor came through the Elvis door
surprising everyone else like they got
their invitations they showed up they're
like what are we doing here this time it
seems like the doctor is the one that
received the invitation and I like the
way he's like this Western gunslinger
with the slide guitar soundtrack
it's a Gallifreyan Civil War and he's
out for revenge so Time Lord Josey Wales
all the way I totally love space
westerns everybody give me your best
Time Lord walks into a bar joke we find
out of course that the doctor doesn't
know who Clara is anymore so Clara's
just playing with him a little bit just
having a little bit of fun and the diner
is actually a TARDIS with the chameleon
circuit activated all in all really
strong intro with the reveal that like
Clara doesn't know who the doctor is the
doctor seems like he's got this WTF face
but he really doesn't know who she is
either my only minor complaint is that
the editing is kind of jumpy way they
cut between the doctors look and the
Doctor Who theme it seems a little
uneven but you see what they're going
for they just want you to be like oh my
god why doesn't Korando who the doctor
is on am i number seven WTF continuing
the theme of the space Western the
doctor like walking across the plains of
Gallifrey to the place where he used to
live Doctor Who High Plains Drifter as
you might have recognized this is the
same barn from the 50th anniversary it's
the same barn that Clara went into
during listen so we can actually kind of
confirm that they were on Gallifrey in
that one episode I remember last year it
was very controversial was like are they
actually on Gallifrey it's supposed to
be in the pocket universe I know it's
really tiny why me but yeah that was
Gallifrey zoom into number 6 WTF in the
high council chamber if you guys didn't
recognize it this is totally maester
Luwin from Game of Thrones of course he
would be present of the Time Lords the
cool thing is is that he later confirms
that this is wrath
he's just like a recast version of the
character he's wearing the hand of
Rassilon he has the seals most new who
fans will probably be more familiar with
Timothy Dalton's performances Rassilon
but I think you can sense a lot of
shades of that character in this
character like I am the all-powerful
president my will be done like the
doctor has the same relationship with
Rassilon at the end of time as he does
in this episode when he mentions the
cloister Bell the closer bells actually
rang earlier this year when the doctor
landed his TARDIS in under the lake in
that underground facility there an
all-purpose is going down alarm
like imagine all your fire alarms going
off at the same time so I just love the
idea that the doctor making landfall on
Gallifrey causes all the cloyster bells
to ring just like oh the doctor is
here he's going to kick everybody's ass
zoom in to number 6 WTF we get to see
the inside of the matrix so if you
haven't watched a whole lot of classic
who you might remember the term the
matrix from the series 8 finale where
Missy had taken a Time Lord matrix and
sucked all these dead souls from earth
into it but the matrix is intended
function was to house the souls of dead
Time Lords so the place we're in right
now is kind of like the Time Lords
mausoleum these crazy figures that are
sliding around that look really evil
those are cloister Ray's they're just
like a protection mechanism a bunch of
ghosts inside a computer protected by
other ghosts outside the really cool
thing we learn though is that if you get
trapped in there the matrix can co-opt
you and use you as a defense mechanism
the explanation the doctor gives is that
these monsters got stuck down there
during the last cloister war and for
those of you that are a little confused
they've never actually done that on
Doctor Who that was just something that
Missy referenced earlier this season the
joke there is that the doctor doesn't
know that Missy told Clara all about it
so like she knows about the president's
wife it wasn't his wife it was his
daughter and I didn't steal the moon I
just lost it when he says I was a
different person back then some of the
words he uses to describe himself sound
a little bit silly so I think he's
talking about the fourth doctor he could
be talking about the sixth doctor there
was a sixth doctor episode where he
battled inside the matrix and then
escaped on a number 5 WTF the doctor
waits for the High Council to come get
him now I know it looks like this woman
here is his mother
the way I think of her though is more of
like the caretaker of this boy's home
like he was just one of many boys that
lived in this
home it wasn't only his home it was like
the place he grew up in there's always a
lot of theories about the doctor's
mother they never given any concrete
answers like a lot of people think that
it's the time lady in white a lot of
people if you've read the expanded
novels then he was actually spun out of
the looms in the expanding materials
they talked about how a gala France have
lost the ability to reproduce naturally
so they spin new gala Franz on genetic
looms they use like the DNA from dead
Gala Franz they might be a bunch of
but at least they recycle but
continuing the theme of the Western in
this episode this is kind of like High
Noon like you just like sitting in the
saloon
waiting for the other gunslingers to
show up and try and kill him I just love
how much this feels like a spaghetti
western we get our first width of the
High Council the doctor tells them to
shove it without actually speaking which
is just awesome if you haven't watched a
lot of westerns or you're not familiar
with what's going on here he's just
basically saying like if you cross this
line I'll destroy you it gets a little
more biblical here just because you have
the david and goliath imagery but you
get the idea look that the doctor is
making his stand against the Timelords
he puts on this other out but it looks
like it has some shades of first doctor
in it that I think is just meant to
invoke some more Clint Eastwood
gunslinger imagery if Clint Eastwood had
been the first doctor on my number four
WTF the doctor versus Rassilon this is
the real gunslinger stand off because
Rassilon is the greatest Time Lord or
greatest villain depending on how you
look at it in Time Lord history yeah
there's the Omega but supposedly
Rassilon killed him the twist being that
even though the Time Lords are supposed
to be the good characters the Daleks are
supposed to be the bad characters
Rassilon himself still walks away being
the villain and the doctor tells him to
shove it just like everyone else get off
my planet and surprise surprise he
actually does end up leaving Rassilon is
super-powerful so I'm just expecting him
to show up sometime in the future he
could always be a potential villain for
future season a doctor who when they say
we're at the end of time there aren't a
lot of places for him to go just means
that he's not going to be gone for
forever
how many regenerations did we give you
I've got all day on my number three WTF
Gallifrey explained so after the doctor
defeats Rassilon or seemingly defeats
them they explain what happened to
Gallifrey they just moved it to the end
of time essentially so where they're at
right now most of their enemies have
died so there really aren't any threats
to them the biggest threat is the doctor
when the doctor says he traveled the law
way round it's not that he had to spend
all that time in the confession dial to
catch up with Gallifrey and time he was
he was trapped in there for however long
the Time Lords wanted have been there
but you get the real sense of extremes
with the doctor going to the end of time
the Time Lords going to the end of time
but you know meant to be like the most
extreme example of time travel on a my
number two WTF the doctor extracts Clara
from her time line essentially you know
pulling the actual car the real Clara
out of time so that he can save her
which regeneration 10 good luck I love
the way he kills this councilmember who
we know from the 50th anniversary who
regenerates into a woman she then goes
on to say that that last regeneration
which he was living as that old man was
her only time to live as a man like
she's always been a woman except for
that one time just a little in joke
about a female doctor like it's totally
possible for Time Lords to be women and
sometimes in the case of this character
they are always women with very few
exceptions car makes the WTF face you
killed somebody Ron Gallifrey dead is
Time Lord from man flew into The
Cloisters the doctor is really just
trying to find a way to steal another
TARDIS all out first doctor and get away
think of all these scenes is like the
final coda for Clara like okay I'm back
so we actually do get the chance to say
goodbye the funniest thing here too is
that he talks about the person that got
stuck in the matrix came out totally
bonkers and cars like wait that was you
right you were the guy that came out of
the matrix and went to it like crazy and
finally I know my number one WTF enter
the hybrid so the doctor finally steals
a TARDIS just just like something
straight out of the first doctor goes to
the actual end of time you know plus or
minus five minutes meets a shield ER
calls her out as the hybrid and she's
like whoa let's hit the pause button
doctor and think about this you in the
master are essentially the hybrid
whether you agree with her or not Moffat
is essentially saying that the doctor is
the hybrid that he's been talking about
the whole time but the thing is is that
the doctor doesn't know that so it's
kind of like false narration when he
says me earlier a lot of people thought
that he was talking about a shield er
when he came out of the confession dial
and said that the hybrid is me because
she calls herself me looking back on it
now I do think that that's what he was
saying like he was saying that it was a
shield er so really I think the takeaway
is that the doctor and Missy are the
hybrid like the most destructive thing
in the history of Gallifrey my only my
nerd is
pointman with this is the card inter not
to be like missing disguise or something
like that but I can understand how that
be a completely rubbish story I was
really disappointed that the master
didn't show up in this episode after a
shield or called her out as being so
important to this hybrid theory so final
thoughts on the ending it was a great
way to end the doctor in Clara's
relationship a nice twist on what
happened with Donna like instead of
wiping her mind the doctor is the one
that got his mind wiped this time if
you're confused the only thing that was
wiped from his mind was car everything
else about this episode he will remember
in when Clarence says to his children
why don't we just take the long way
round back to Gallifrey you know Cara's
gonna go back to her death just gonna
have a little bit of fun on the way it's
just her ride off into the sunset it's a
little bit happier than a being Rory's
ending she isn't wrapped in some
never-ending debt so it's kind of sad
but it's not dying whale sounds sad and
I'm really digging the look of the new
Sonic I think that final moment with the
doctor you know where he snaps the door
shut just to make you feel like okay
business as usual now you guys let me
know in the comments what was your
favorite mode in this episode the moment
that made you stand up and scream and
what do you think about the way that
they left Clara's character what do you
think about her ending compared to other
companions remember we do have the
Christmas episode coming up I will
totally do a Christmas special trailer
sometime this weekend it's going to be
all about River Song the title is called
the husbands of River Song I like that
it's a play on the doctor's wife it
makes it sound like it's almost going to
be told from rivers perspective and I've
already seen a lot of confusion about
what husbands means like most titles it
means a couple different things at the
same time but I think the obvious
reference is that even though River
married the 11th doctor physically she
was marrying all the different versions
of the doctor's so she has 13 different
husbands counting the war doctor but all
in all it was a great episode and it was
a loads better than the series 8 finale
hand over fist flipped the table over
better
so why gives me for that Christmas
special video you can click here for
that Game of Thrones Season 6 teaser and
you can click here for all my other
Doctor Who videos from this year thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight